advice from dana white from zuga 101  find your passion  a lot of times kids go to college and  take a major because they do what they  think they're supposed to do  i told them i believe 90 percent of  america gets up in the morning and  drives to a job they hate  that could have happened to me in the  hotel industry  i told them to find what they are  passionate about and to go for that  regardless of what anyone tells them  they can go to school and major in  political science and say they want to  be a doctor or lawyer but unless they're  passionate about what they do they're  never really going to be happy or truly  successful  for more check out zugo 101 find your  passion in the link below